[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got austin here how you
doing man great to be here pomp
absolutely all right we're gonna get
started with the biggest news probably
earlier this year which was
uh you raised a hundred million dollar
series a where did that come from
we were at the right time at the right
place with great execution by a great
team so we've been working on tax and
accounting software for consumers
enterprises and governments to really
fuel
widespread adoption of cryptocurrency so
it was awesome to see it all come
together
yeah and when you think about the
product right you said that you
serve the retail users you serve the
corporations or the enterprise customer
and then also governments maybe let's
just walk through like how does a
retail user interact with the tax and
accounting software that you guys build
yeah so tax software in crypto to date
has been primarily retail driven meaning
the burden or obligation is on all of us
as crypto users
to go and compile your data and report
your taxes properly
and so our product commonly referred to
you know as the turbo tax of crypto
is do it yourself link your exchanges
link your wallets
and then we produce your tax forms and
feed those into turbo tax or over to
your account
on the back end well a few years ago we
knew
that that model wasn't going to last at
some point exchanges
and the actual broker dealers banks
financial institutions
um were going to issue 1099s and
actually going to help the users
compile their taxes natively within
their applications and so
we set out to go and build
professional-grade cloud-based native
very secure software for the enterprise
in order to you know furnish those 1099s
and provide users
with an experience within the
applications that they use on a
day-to-day basis and so
we're excited about uh our client list
on that side so that's the enterprise
market
and then the government side of things
just a couple of weeks ago we announced
that the irs selected us
um as their cryptocurrency tax offer
provider and so
that's just the beginning we've got so
many governments around the world
looking for software to help them just
really
get in compliance with the tax
regulations of their countries and so
that's an exciting market for us as well
so i think people understand the retail
market i think they understand
the uh kind of enterprise market when
the irs says that you're their tax
software partner what does that mean
yeah so what we can say obviously that
means a lot and there's 18 months of a
long relationship here and rfp process
but they
are using our software and data feeds in
order to
audit the accuracy of what taxpayers are
filing with them or
not filing with them if a taxpayer
failed to file and they said hey what do
i owe
and the irs will come to us and say okay
you know what what does that look like
and so we're helping them
from that perspective and then there's
some other things that are in the works
as well that we can
talk about as time progresses okay and
then you also have accounting software
so the way that i think about this is
uh the flow of funds or capital through
uh retail enterprise and then ultimately
the government kind of overseeing a lot
of this
uh is applicable to taxes but it's also
applicable just on a day-to-day basis
how to run my business
so i gotta manage my portfolio and so
that's where the accounting stuff comes
in but like what do those products look
like great question pomp so this
actually started from a kind of this
land and expand model as we were
integrating our enterprise tax clients
they came to us and said hey
you're running gains and losses for all
of our users real time it's incredible
no one is doing that for us as an entity
for gaap or ifrs
accounting purposes and so they're like
hey we're struggling to get a big for
auditor
or to take us on as a client to actually
think about any sort of spac
ipo or liquidity event because we don't
even have audited financials it's taking
us months to close our books
and so we set out with them very high
end top of the market
to go build the first big four sec grade
sub
ledger kind of an erp of cryptocurrency
that feeds back into your net suites
your oracles and saps
well as you can imagine as we're seeing
institutional adoption of crypto this
product
is going to be huge for any institution
that holds crypto on their balance sheet
but or accepted it as means of payment
and we're starting to see a lot more
adoption on that side of things as
paypal or at least merchants spend to 30
million merchants now and
and other corporations are starting to
accept it as a currency and so
that will automate their books and
accounting from their journal entries to
their asset and liability reserves to
their gains and losses
and so much more in real time yeah and
so
if you raise 100 million dollar series a
uh somebody gave you 100 million dollars
we could talk about who those people are
in a second
um but there's got to be growth right
there's got to be some value there's got
to be some validation of this so like
what metrics can you share about just
the tax bit business and how it's grown
over the last two or three years
yeah so we issued i think in the
hundreds of thousands
of tax forms prior to this year this
year it was
many millions of tax forms so
exponential growth probably
uh close to 100x on a number of
users and and kind of latency of our
software and then we've also grown
headcount i mean we're doubling our team
i swear every month right now so
coming up on 70 people will be over 100
here in the coming weeks
or months i should say adding you know
five people a week right now
and then as we grow internationally this
isn't just a problem in the united
states pomp like
cryptocurrency is property it's not
cryptocurrency it's crypto property and
that's something like
80 of the world's countries and so this
has to be solved across the globe
in order for cryptocurrency to continue
to proliferate so you guys have grown
i think you've become by far the leader
in this space both from
uh the people who are behind you the
capital that you've raised the
head count the software the users the
relationship with
uh enterprises governments et cetera
like i don't want to say that you have
won because that would insinuate that
it's over
but you definitely are the leader right
in terms of this stuff uh
one of the things i'm really interested
in is uh recently el salvador announced
that they were going to make
uh bitcoin legal tender uh then that
kind of kicked off this domino effect of
like everyone in south america now has
laser eyes on twitter
exactly right there's politicians in
like every country south and central
america
which one is awesome but two is i don't
even understand and i think most people
don't understand
what the implications if el salvador
actually does make bitcoin legal tender
does that then make some of these tax
complexities in the united states
uh smaller does it remove them or does
it actually not matter and some of this
is like people
are kind of wishful thinking yeah and i
think el salvador it's an incredible
announcement obviously argentina is
close to my heart i lived there for a
couple years so really excited to see
the adoption there and i just saw
firsthand the inflation problems and the
poverty that people were dealing with
there so bitcoin i'm a huge believer
obviously for the utility behind that
from a tax perspective 70 of people in
el salvador like don't even have bank
accounts so we're not
talking about taxes right now or is the
president where is that the focus like
we're talking about putting food on
people's table
and so i think we're going to start to
see more developments on the tax side in
latin america and more of these
third world countries on what that looks
like and so the answer right now is
there hasn't been any
like guidance or even hints at what that
looks like for these latin american
countries
well what about in the in the united
states in the sense of if el salvador
makes it legal tender then does that
mean it's a foreign currency in the
united states and therefore
uh it's no longer the crypto property
you were talking about it now becomes a
crazy
or how does that yeah it won't change
the treatment here in the united states
so can el salvador
residents and citizens in those
countries to be tbd so we're going to
see on there
but here in the u.s it's property
anything that fluctuates in value
is a capital asset your car is a capital
asset technically if you sold that for a
gain
obviously that's you know highly
unlikely is it's a depreciable asset
and so that's how the irs has looked at
it and it's the same way as equities and
real estate and anything else that has
increased or decrease in value this
brings me to
uh a topic that most people don't know
about
the wealthiest of the world know all
about this uh there's something called
tax loss
harvesting and we recently saw a report
come out
i think it's pro publica did it where
they got access to the tax returns of
very very wealthy people
and uh i don't remember the exact
numbers but it was like less than four
percent
income tax is what they were paying now
people that's the headline everyone
yells and screams whatever uh
we should caveat like wealthy people
don't make most of their money from
income they make it from capital gains
and other types of
uh wealth generation events and most of
their wealth is in a
unrealized gain uh kind of status
therefore they don't pay taxes until
they actually sell it or monetize
or whatever but they also understand
this idea of tax loss harvesting so
maybe describe
what exactly is tax loss harvesting and
then we can talk about how that applies
to crypto and what you guys are doing
with it i think it's the most
hidden treasure in wealth generation
that there is i think most people know
wealth is generated by assets it's by
equity ownership it's by owning things
that appreciate
but when you own assets unfortunately
everything isn't linear up into the
right
is up and to the right over time with
dips along the way and so what's not
talked about enough
is how taking advantage of those dips
selling harvesting a loss and then
legally repurchasing your position back
in at the right time
in order to continue to appreciate over
the long term
that's tax loss harvesting and so as you
do that
all of those losses start to accumulate
and losses carry forward
you can't carry them back so losses
today are better than losses tomorrow
harvest them anytime you can and you
keep stacking them people
talk about stacking sats and bitcoin
stack losses and then when you
ultimately do convert to fiat
not that you should in crypto as
bitcoin's gonna rule the world right um
but when you do you have this whole you
know treasure chest of losses that
offset capital gains
almost entirely if you do it right and
so in that article i
i was a big fan of reading that but that
was the one piece that wasn't talked
about was
even when these people these wealthy
individuals do cash back to fiat
that's why you're seeing such small
percentages four percent five percent
is they've harvested losses along the
way so forget crypto for a second if
this was just the regular stock market
and let's say i bought a stock at
ten dollars uh it goes up to 15
and then all of a sudden it goes back
down to eight dollars uh and i actually
sell the stock at eight dollars i
book a two dollar loss right and so if i
then got paid two dollars at work as
part of income or whatever i basically
could
negate the two dollars of income with
the two dollars of the
loss from the investment basic over
generalization
now in the equity market there's all
sorts of rules around wash
trading which basically means i can't go
sell the stock and then immediately buy
it right back there's a period of time i
can't
actually own the stock and it makes a
little bit harder to do this
in the equity market in the crypto
market though those rules don't apply uh
as of now maybe they will in the future
but right now they don't apply
that's correct they apply to securities
cryptocurrency's property right now and
so
it's not a loophole i think it's a known
item it's uh going to come up in the in
the future
it's a you know low agenda item right
now there's still this whole
infrastructure behind cryptocurrency and
a movement happening
where we're going to see a lot and but
here's the thing in the equity world
what the most savvy people are doing is
they're not waiting 30 days to
repurchase their position in their asset
they're repurchasing a position in a 95
correlated asset immediately
holding that during the 30-day wait
period and then going back into their
original asset
so software does that software can run
all these correlations in statistical
regression tables
tax bits doing this in preparation you
know for wash sale rules on both
we're not just a cryptocurrency company
anymore we support commodities and
equities
and this whole gamut of assets um but
that's the power there
is you can start to get creative
especially in crypto
like how many types of bitcoin are there
bitcoin wrapped bitcoin
um you know so many different things
that are tied to the price of bitcoin
that's going to help to get around wash
sale rules in the event that those ever
do apply
and so what do you guys do with tax loss
harvesting today like how can i use
taxbix software either as a retail user
or through an enterprise product for tax
loss harvesting yeah let me tell you
about it so
let's start on the consumer side any one
of uh cryptocurrency investors right now
can go sign up at taxbid.com
do it yourself link your exchange
accounts you're going to have this whole
tax optimization module you're going to
be able to go in there
and see all of your outstanding cost
basis lots that sum up to what you own
and you're going to see them by source
where they're being stored what
exchanges etc wallets
and you can start to see okay now as of
right now
i have a loss and this lot i should
select that lot go and sell it
um you're going to see the software
update real time and and you know
decrease your taxable gains or take you
to a lost position and start to
accumulate those losses and so you can
do that
across all the platforms that you hold
assets in
uh through taxbit consumer where we're
going and
lots of announcements that i'm excited
to share is you're not going to have to
use taxbid consumer
for much longer we have an amazing list
of clients that we're actively
implementing right now
dozens where the same platforms that
you're using on a day-to-day basis
through your mobile apps you're gonna be
able to do this natively within their
application
tax center tabs are coming to the
industry and it's an end-to-end
experience to be able to harvest losses
straight on those platforms
um and set notifications set automated
trades and alerts
and so many other things and so we're
excited to share more in some way
uh shopify's entire motto is like arm
the rebels
right there's no greater rebel than the
bitcoin and kind of cryptocurrency
industry
and so really what you guys are doing is
you're trying to take these very
sophisticated strategies these
uh in many cases complex computational
um kind of technologies that have been
built for the ultra rich
and you're now trying to almost bring
that to uh the everyday retail user
whether it's they go directly to
taxpayer or they're gonna eventually at
some point be able to use it in actual
uh exchanges or wallets that they use on
a day-to-day basis that's exactly right
and i'm
we're democratizing tax usually you need
to go and pay an attorney or a you know
cpa and
they do this for wealthy individuals how
can we bring this to the masses so every
day people
can harvest losses it's not hundreds of
thousands of dollars but you know tens
or hundreds of dollars that
is most more typical in america today
for middle america
yeah is there anything else that you see
that people who are
interested in reducing tax bills that
like a wealthy strategy that they should
be thinking about here in crypto and
that's much more like an advice
standpoint but like tax loss harvesting
is a great idea
right are there other things that you
guys have either built into the product
or you think that people should be aware
of
so there's a variety of ways to harvest
losses and you know
selling is one of them but
cryptocurrency
ultimately we want it to have utility as
a currency vehicle and
spending is a taxable event and so when
you think about actually using crypto
there are ways that you can use crypto
to optimize your taxes in a tax
beneficial way similar to loss
harvesting
but also donate for those that are
charitable minded out there
donations are one of the most
fascinating topics that so many high net
worth people do
because everything that you donate is
tax free from a capital gain perspective
if you're in a long-term status all of
that you get credit for a charitable
deduction at the fair market value at
the time you donated it
and it is tax-free and so you're double
dipping from the charitable contribution
and the tax free on the appreciation so
we're helping a lot of people on the
charity
side and then as well the tax loss
harvesting side by either selling or
using crypto
today the product it feels like is uh
manual and kind of opt-in right
it seems like though eventually you want
to get to more of like an automated
solution
and so is this like a version of almost
like a robo advisor for
taxes kind of like the end result here
yeah i think that's exactly right we're
starting to see
if we can bring the tools straight to
those platforms hand you your tax forms
at your end
you can do everything from your mobile
app most of the time you're not even
going to know that tax bit is the
provider in the background making this
all happen
that's what that's when we know we've
succeeded is when every single person is
using tax bit
on a day-to-day basis without even
knowing yeah what's so fascinating to me
about you guys
is you come from a very strict kind of
finance
accounting background in terms of uh
previous success
um in uh in salt lake city i think you
guys were right yep
and you stayed there and now you've
opened a second office my understanding
is in seattle
and so most people would not think of
salt lake city
or seattle as the places to go build
crypto business so maybe talk about kind
of
uh what brought you to salt lake city
why you stayed and started and then
the second headquarters in seattle yeah
i mean the whole tax bit story is
unconventional to begin with i mean i
left so i started my career at qualtrics
rapid growing sas company
turned down the big four i'm a cpa so
you know that's the safe career
path my parents everyone thought i was
nuts and so joined this startup their
first accountant ever
and it was hyper growth you know
controller of their worldwide operations
writing their s1
leading out on m a deals doing
everything and so i was able to grow so
quick there
and that story was a utah basement story
founded by ryan smith who now owns the
jazz
incredible guy an investor in us as part
of this round um
as your yourself pomp we should talk a
little bit about that too
um so as i've gone through that
utah's just flourished we brought in so
much talent over the last 10 years
to qualtrics and all these other
companies it's called silicon slopes
right now right
and so it's an amazing place the dollar
goes a long way
the weather's incredible you got the
mountains there's so much to do
that we're okay we need to you know take
advantage and harvest this ecosystem
here
well seattle i grew up there like i'm
from there and so
when you look at it um that was
logically the next place where okay
there's a lot of good talent there to
similar business models as uh stripe
avalera you know api providers that's
who we are and so that just made sense
uh the dollar goes a little bit farther
than you know manhattan or san francisco
and so that was where we're going for
you know product and dev
to go faster and more at speed um
so yeah i think you know we started in a
basement ourself my brother and i
tax attorney cpa and people were
thinking we were nuts it was 2017
crypto taxes that's an oxymoron like
people go into crypto to
avoid taxes to do money laundering and
so we just kept building and building
and building we were in stealth mode for
many years building this enterprise
professional security that could scale
to billions of transactions at the
enterprise level
and really fortunate now that
cryptocurrencies just hit this wave
that we were ready and so it is a little
unconventional but uh perfect timing
salt lake city in seattle now i think
people are starting to recognize okay we
can recruit people here
uh we're recording this in miami you're
here for the bitcoin conference what are
your thoughts on the conference and on
miami miami is blowing up right now i
love it here
the conference was incredible i've been
coming to these conferences for four
years this one was
unlike anything else um just there was a
line half a mile around the block to try
and get in and you know these these
tickets aren't cheap this isn't general
admission these are people
i was talking to couples who drove eight
hours here just a husband and a wife
um that aren't high net worth
individuals they're just
fascinated by this like this is their
life and so really cool to see the
amount of energy
but not just on the retail side
institutional adoption is here
um bitcoin's here and so we're starting
to see fortune 500 companies
big funds hedge funds administrators
they're taking this seriously large
banks traditional banks
up and comers um it's here to stay and
so this is a great time and great place
to be here in miami
yeah and so when you think about kind of
developing a global workforce
uh we were talking about forehand and
you guys are actually having this hybrid
model so some people are like oh we're
all remote so we're like everyone get
back in the office like
walk through coming out of kovid how you
thought about
you know hey i run a business that's got
tens of people that worked there
have you thought about coming in the
office not going in the office and like
what works for you guys
yeah so obviously we wanted to get
feedback from our team first and
foremost and
the overwhelming feedback was when we
were an office company five days a week
prior to covid
and you know there were times where
people said hey like can i work remote
and we didn't know
we didn't feel good about that right
like that wasn't the norm well as we
went to covid
it was completely flipped on its head
everyone remote
and that got tiring and strenuous and
the feedback was man
what i would do to like have
face-to-face interaction again and so as
we've now
shifted to vaccinations available the
feedback was
i want the best of both worlds i want
face-to-face interaction i want the
camaraderie the energy
the hallway whiteboard moments that
happen with that but i also want to lock
myself in my room at times and just be
heads down and get
knocked [ __ ] out and so um you know
that's what we've that's what we've
incorporated and we're starting to see
that not just at our company but so many
large fortune 500
companies three days a week in office
two days a week remote
um really just being flexible with
people and is it like monday wednesday
friday you have to be in the office
tuesday thursday do whatever you want is
it like hey what
what days do you want to be out of the
office first in the office like how do
you think about um
is it team specific like just like
operationalizing you know
kind of this hybrid model for us monday
and friday are the mandatory days we do
all hands team meetings we bring in
lunch those days we do
all of kind of our events our goals and
and those and the and the like those
days
then the other day is team specific hey
get together with your pod or your team
and figure out what works best for you
so just being flexible there
got it um as you look forward taxes are
only going to become a bigger and bigger
idea uh one uh we see
lots of cities and states now saying
wait a minute this industry there's a
lot of wealth generation there's a lot
of companies being built
all that stuff like maybe we want them
based here right whatever
the city or state is because there's tax
revenue associated with it
uh two there's jobs associated with it
so how do you
see like the next couple of years when
it comes to the intersection of crypto
and taxes is there
uh things around enforcement is there
things around like the accounting aspect
is there things around maybe trading
that you're excited about like what is
it that you're like okay these are the
things to watch over the next couple
years
yeah so i think we've already hit a lot
of inflection points i mean
uh coinbase's large ipo is one of the
largest in tech
and blackrock visa paypal rolling this
out to the masses
institutional adoption is something i
keep my eye on more more so than the
price of bitcoin
i ignore that it's all about adoption in
my mind but i think the second
is cryptocurrency has not been a
currency today people aren't
transacting that point of sale and so
over the next couple of years
i do foresee that changing where it
makes sense to spend currency from a tax
perspective at times
but also ease of use and transaction
fees and
just the electronic nature of it so i
think that's another thing that we're
going to start to see
and then third i think just disruption
of the underlying technology
blockchain as a whole what that can do
to
property titles to the whole accounting
profession where i can you know have an
immutable
cap table and balance sheet and all
right there that's you know
trustless and verifiable and so i start
once we start to see those
three things start to happen where this
is disrupting not just finance but
technology from the core way of doing
things the legacy way
i i think that's coming in the next 24
months hey guys what's going on before
we continue with this awesome episode i
want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
kraken's been a longtime supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app all right
let's get back into this episode i hope
you're enjoying this one
yeah it's really interesting too where
uh
i'm an investor in taxbid i'm an
investor in block five so let's use
those two as examples
uh and block five is one of the early
partners that's starting to incorporate
some of the tax software
uh it's like a no-brainer when you talk
to the executive team right they're like
of course our users need tax help right
like
and we want to be able to do that and
some of it's like we're gonna remain in
good standing with regulators and with
the irs and things like that and
in power uh with the right documentation
and some of it's just like
it's just a good experience for them
right it actually helps our customers be
more successful and therefore of course
we want to do it
and so it feels like this is inevitable
that
every single company is going to
incorporate
the reporting going to incorporate it
natively inside the software
like there's just this element of like
duh
right i mean it sounds like you've had
that idea now for a couple of years but
like
it feels like now people are waking up
and it's becoming very obvious that this
is where we're going
yeah that's exactly right we obviously
love the block fight team
and you know you can connect your tax
bid account all your transactions right
there within their app
you know with one click and your taxes
are done well just wait for what's
coming there's so many more
announcements between our two companies
around the corner it's even going to
take this to a whole nother level
but that's how the equity industry has
existed pomp is
you don't have to go and figure this
[ __ ] out on yourself the equity brokers
have those tax center tabs and
they help you out and so the hurdle here
this wasn't something we
invented per se the idea the technology
hurdle was the hurdle this is a
different asset class it's voluminous
there's transfers on and off platform
there's forks there's airdrops there's
all these complications coin for coin
trades that don't exist in the equity
space
and so that's why it took us a long time
you know three years in stealth mode
grinding this out just working on the
tech to be able to scale to the masses
so it was inevitable to us and
it's really exciting to see and i think
throughout this year you're going to see
taxpayer become a household name um with
so many of the largest broker dealers
lending platforms banks
and not just in the cryptocurrency space
but in the equities and commodities and
whole tokenized economy space yeah it's
fascinating when you start to think
about uh
bitcoin then the cryptocurrencies then
tokenize equities and you kind of keep
going out
but from a tax software provider doesn't
really matter
right you just need to know what the
asset is right but from a technology
interface standpoint if everything is
digitized actually might be easier for
you
right like it may make you more
effective rather than there being all
these different platforms and different
technologies and whatever like if
everything is just digitized
game on that's exactly right you're here
to power it all
how do you think about uh from a tax
perspective
um if i've got a platform and there can
be all kinds of different platforms
where i've got cryptocurrencies i've got
something that looks more like
commodities that are digitized
equities that are digitized etc uh is
that something where you guys think you
know hey we're gonna service one account
it's gonna hold multiple assets and like
that's gonna be
uh our interface with the client or do
you feel like we're gonna get a
replication
of the legacy financial world where you
know i have an account for my equities i
have an account for
any commodities that i own usually i've
got an account for maybe currencies i've
got an account for my bank itself
right and my savings account or checking
account like how do you see this playing
out and how are you guys building your
software to
uh be ready for this i think it's all
coming together i think
we're entering the 21st century of
banking i think traditional banks are
shaking in their boots right now
um and we're gonna start to see
tokenization i call it the tokenized
economy
across all assets commodities equities
uh
cryptocurrency real estate you can
tokenize anything in the future and so
i'm obviously very bullish in forward
thinking here and
some might call me crazy but yeah being
able to do all that within one platform
or
you know it won't be one winner it's not
going to be a winner take all for all of
finance but
uh you know the ease of use having all
of your asset management
right there platform specific and then
having tax
and accounting built on integrated into
that is super powerful and
you're gonna be able to really take
advantage of your wealth and your
situation and control it much easier
than traditional finance today
yeah um what are the downsides to all of
this
right so when you were talking to
investors or you were talking to
potential partners or customers like
what are the
things that make them hesitant or like
risk that they associate is it
just a prioritization thing like we
always talk about all the good things
that are happening right but like what
do you think are the the things that
fall in the bucket of
hey here's feedback we get that either
we're working on or as an overall
industry we've got to improve uh to kind
of you know become more sophisticated
yeah i mean any entrepreneur will tell
you even when things are going great
it's hard as hell
and so there's you know fires to put out
on a day-to-day basis
we're hyper growth mode i mean half of
our team wasn't here two months ago and
so
you've got people onboarding and
training new employees that have only
been here three months so
talking about culture and how you scale
it's chaos and it's always chaos under
the hood of the fastest growing tech
company so
it's exciting it's challenging it's fun
um from our business in particular
privacy and security are at the
forefront like we take that so seriously
um we're investing so much there and
you know there's a lot to do and there
always is anyone that says that they've
arrived when it comes to privacy and
security
i'd be you know very weary of and so um
we aren't an asset custodian
that's great we're uh you know api in
with read-only access to
to see data but anything that touches
your financial well-being is sensitive
in my mind and
that needs to be guard guarded super
secure and so that's something that
we take seriously and that we obviously
stay close with investors and our board
on
um the industry in general i think in
order for cryptocurrency to exist and
i'm so proud of the industry
first and foremost because this could
have went two ways in 2017.
regulators could have shut this down and
said no we have no kyc
we have no tax enforcement like that
breaks all the foundational backbones of
how america was built but they gave it a
chance and they said okay we're gonna
let this play out
and we're gonna you know allow the
practitioners in the industry
to go and solve the kyc the um you know
aml
and the tax and accounting challenges
and you know fortunately
tax bit you know solve that on the tax
and accounting side and other providers
on the aml kyc side
but we have a long ways to go when you
talk about d5 how are we going to
scale that and those sorts of protocols
to the decentralized world because i'm a
huge d5 fan
and defense decentralized lending and
borrowing is incredible
um but tax evasion money laundering
can't happen
and so as soon as that stuff starts to
creep in we've all got to be you know
mature enough to realize if this
industry is going to be around and go to
the masses
we've got to do it in a regulated way
and that's my opinion and it would be
quite drains when you think about the
decentralized space it's interesting
because right now most of it is you go
direct to the user
or you go to centralized entities but if
the dominant use case becomes
decentralized infrastructure
uh is there a way for you to kind of
plug in and still automate some of this
or is it going to be completely reliant
on the individuals coming and kind of
uploading information and that's that's
the piece that can't happen just you
know
conversations with the irs and others
like voluntary tax reporting has never
worked in society
the 20 years ago the equity space all
changed 1099 b's came out
because voluntary tax reporting wasn't
working there's this massive tax gap is
what
the irs defines what is what is that a
tax the tax cap means it's the gap
between number of people that should be
reporting and number of people that
actually do
and so as you close this tax gap um
that's when you know assets start to
have mainstream adoption because
regulators are getting behind them and
embracing them right now in
cryptocurrency there was a massive tax
gap and the number of people
actually that should have been reporting
has been low and so you know issuing
1099s and the irs
starting to enforce this at the exchange
level is how that tax gap can start to
close as the irs
has kyc and taxpayer information and so
if you don't file it's a robotic audit
you're going to get audited and so
there's really kind of no more option
here
so the decentralized world my hypothesis
is we're going to start to see the next
generation of tech companies on the kyc
front
how can we layer on some of this
standard protocols that exist in the
centralized space
and then you know take that to the next
level so you know firsthand
conversations with
our investors and so many others um
there there's a lot of uh
innovation to happen yeah it's
interesting when you think i think i one
time
saw and i'll probably get the numbers
wrong but directionally correct
uh it was like 14 000 people one year
reported taxes for crypto and it was
like you know
one exchange had like 200 000 people on
it let alone all the other exchanges
and so this tax gap i guess is like that
was really really big at one point i'm
assuming that it's become
much lower but there's still a gap there
is that fair
yeah yeah and it's going to close even
further and further so exchanges are
starting to file you're seeing subpoenas
across
popular exchanges issued by the irs and
so
there's a lot more we're still in the
early innings not just in crypto in
general but
the compliance and regulatory side of
things too so yeah it'll continue to
close
and i think coinbase is s1 just brought
a lot of knowledge to the space about
how many people in america are
transacting and they publish those
quarterly reports and
um so that's been fascinating to see how
important is it the u.s
tax regime versus like other countries
or other countries
uh this sophisticated this kind of um
the only word i can think of is
overbearing but that's kind of a
negative connotation to it but just
uh i think so focused on this uh or is
that a global thing this happens in
every single country and that's an
opportunity for you guys
it'll vary country by country obviously
you know some people are going to move
offshores and
there's some lenient countries out there
but overwhelmingly i think
probably 80 percent of the countries
treat this as a capital asset that have
some sort of gain and loss
reporting associated with every
transaction tied to it and so
the irs has always been one of the
highest enforcing tax governments in the
world
um but you've got the uk tax authority
the australian tax office the
canadian revenue agency they're taking
it seriously too you're seeing uk
subpoenas
across popular platforms all the time
and so it's not u.s specific
by any means it sounds like uh similar
to institutions institutions hated
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies until they
figured out how they could make money
from it now they love it
right governments are kind of the same
thing right of like oh we can't figure
out how to like collect taxes or
whatever
as they become more effective at doing
that should we
anticipate uh more
friendliness towards the industry
whether it's the united states or
elsewhere it's just like
there's almost like a financial
incentive there i think so actually okay
yeah i think in 2017 it almost felt like
there was this conflict you had industry
and you had government
and just working firsthand with
government
here in 2021 it doesn't feel that way
anymore i know so many government people
that are that own bitcoin themselves
that are using it
and so it's feeling like as we you know
make
progress towards more regulatory
compliance that we're starting to bridge
that gap and that's that's huge for the
industry
yeah it feels like um the financial
incentive's very strong
right if all of a sudden now uh a
government can figure out how to make
money from it right and make money is
just
taxation uh there's likely to be that uh
but also it also feels like um
it's kind of a jaywalking example right
jaywalking is technically illegal but if
you can't enforce it is it really
illegal in new york city
on paper right it's kind of been
decriminalized to some degree unless
they really want to be a stickler right
if you have rules around taxation and
all of this but you can't actually
enforce it
are they real rules right and it feels
like that is kind of where
the evolution maybe is coming from uh
which
you know to be fair and we should have
said this at some point in the the
episode for sure
is like there's a very big group of the
crypto community that absolutely
hates taxes thinks taxation is theft and
uh will do everything possible in their
power to prevent
taxation from uh increasing or being
uh evaluated and uh carried out
i understand where they're coming from
i'm a cpa i hate taxes when i do my
taxes at your end yeah it's not a
pleasant thing
yes but it's the law exactly right
it's um uh it's kind of like the
accreditation laws
i always say like i think they're stupid
i think they should change yes
but i'm still only gonna take money in a
fund from accredited investors if that's
what the rules say right because i don't
want to get in trouble
taxation feels similar to me it's like i
don't actually don't know anybody who's
like
increasing taxes is a good idea on just
that premise now maybe it's
you know we should go do something with
the money what like all you get into
more of the political
stuff but taxation at its core nobody
likes it
yeah it's just they don't want to get in
trouble and so that
feeling overwhelms the the feeling of
hating taxes
uh for you guys though it almost feels
you're taking a position i'm like look
you you said it right like i don't like
taxes but if that's going to be the rule
then like
let's help people make sure that they're
compliant let's help people actually
some cases d uh lower their taxes with
the tax loss harvesting right that's
it how can you know we take this unsexy
topic that people hate even
the professionals like myself um and
make it a little bit more sexy people
like saving money they like
keeping the dollars that they've hard
earned that you know they're working
every day for they like keeping those in
their pockets
and so how can we help people do that in
a legal way
in a tax beneficial way to them and so
that's where i get really excited about
our business
is um the end result of keeping people
in compliance with the law in a way that
you know is most beneficial for them
yeah
it's uh it's absolutely fascinating
before i let you go uh
two questions for you but aliens again
two opportunities no no no
you've already answered all my dumb
questions uh if you had to pitch people
right now
from a user standpoint what's the pitch
for why they should use taxbid
so taxpay first and foremost cpas tax
attorneys founded we now have dozens of
on our subject matter expert team you're
going to be in good hands you're going
to know that you have the most accurate
solution out there
we've resolved thousands of irs audits
we've got your back all the time the irs
uses our software
second you're going to have human to
human interaction our customer support
team
are real people in salt lake in seattle
not offshored you're going to get the
best of the best
that really understand u.s taxation
themselves so you're going to have that
experience
third the exchanges are using tax bid
the platforms that you use
are using tax bit many of them and so um
just know that that whole ecosystem and
the power and the seamlessness
we're improving we just raised 100
million dollars to make our software
better
each and every week and so the tax bit
you use today is not going to be the tax
bit that you use three months from now
there's gonna be so many new rollouts
and and things that just only get better
and so we're here for the long term
we're going to be doing this for the
next decade plus this is what we live
and breathe and love and so
um i hope our passion you know reflects
to the community and we can help
all right second that's a good pitch by
the way uh second pitch
is to potential partners exchanges etc
uh what's the pitch to them as to why
they should partner with you you should
absolutely reach out to us
our enterprise page as soon as you see a
demo um of how it's not just going to
get you in compliance with the irs
it's going to drive transaction volume
net new users a better user experience
natively to your interface
full liability on all of your
information reporting you know how many
times
you know founders are losing sleep on
the exchange level of compliance on the
tax side
we're taking that all on we're that
confident in everything we do
so reach out to us you'll see a demo and
you're going to be hooked and you'll
understand why so many of the leaders
are quickly implementing i was also a
good pitch
i mean listen you got to pay taxes
whether you like it or not
you guys are helping individuals do that
and lower their tax bills and you're
helping
exchanges and other infrastructure
become more compliant and provide a
better user experience
kind of a no-brainer it's a win-win for
everyone yeah
that makes sense exactly who were the
investors
in the last round let's maybe finish up
there you i mean
no no need to stop so i was like the
smallest investor
so tiger global and paradigm were the
co-leads
and so really you know outstanding
investors there no one's ever heard of
either one of those i doubt it very
small firms yeah
exactly incredible helpful people there
and then we had an amazing syndicate
from
industry galaxy paypal gemini
coinbase and then just strong
influencers such as yourself
uh ryan smith the owner of the jazz um
you know bill ackman a good friend of
mine great team over there
and so many others i'm missing 30 others
literally that's just spacing my mind
but powerful team
yeah it's um it just feels like you've
raised a lot of money you got the right
people around the table now
and so uh let's go let's do it let's go
all right taxbid.com is where we should
send people yep that's right follow us
on twitter as well
ooh follow on twitter sounds like he
threw that stuff
all right man listen thank you so much
for doing this i'll do it again in the
future great to be here pomp